ja hallo hier ist ein euro trinkgeld du
ganz ganz ganz kurz noch bevor du jetzt
da wieder zurück ist ich wollte nur
sagen 1000 deswegen so ein mörder
unterwegs naja herzlichkeit zu diesem
neuen liebe leute wir uns heute auf dem
kanal eingefunden denn ich habe ein
video gefunden was uns sehr gut
unterhalten könnte wenn wir uns zusammen
anschauen und zwar entweder weil video
von einer youtube über die ich vor
einiger zeit glaube ich schon ein video
gemacht habe es ist nicht nur besser
sondern jemand der bäcker bringt sehr
ähnlich ist die gute dame heißt bonnie
träsch die gute dem ersten video
hochgeladen das heißt halloween wird zur
horror nacht in diesem video tut sie so
als würde sie von irgendeinem mörder
verfolgt werden selbstverständlich die
ganze sache ist habe ich erst mal
genauer anschauen und analysieren
bestand der kran hatte wie immer gilt
wenn ihr einen 50 euro gutschein
gewinnen wollt dann sagt immer unter den
ersten zwanzig leute die mal wieder
kommentieren ein obwohl ich mir die 20
ersten unter ihrem video raus und
verlost unter den diesen gutschein also
ja so einfach schnell und ich will jetzt
auch schnell den williams muss stabil
[Musik]
also das video beginnt erst recht
unscheinbar sie hier ist und weil sich
zuhause bereitet eine halloween party
vor
denn wir haben den titel gelesen heute
halloween wird zu hart es ist also der
halloween abend im zuhause von contrave
die ganze sache begann wie gesagt mit
dem schrecken aber dann schreitet der
abend fort da kommt ihre freundin an wie
man das natürlich so unter normalen
leuten macht hat die dabei eine kamera
laufen während sie gerade ihre freunde
an der tür begrüßt und hallo sagt ich
erwarte dass selbstverständlich auch
immer so vermeiden freuen wenn ich
irgend jemand versucht ist das absolute
vorschrift dass die leute filmen wie ich
die tür aufmachen weil sonst ein freund
sein okay soweit ist aber auch alles
nochmal so die beiden freundinnen
stellen sowie als würde man irgendwie so
den normalen halloweenabend film
schminken sich gegenseitig und alles ist
ganz normal
aber dann beginnen die dinge bisschen
aus dem ruder zu laufen und zwar stimmen
auf einmal so die kameraaufnahmen nicht
mehr ganz mit
auf einmal sind in dem video im film
aufnahmen von draußen rein geschnitten
das ist dann wohl an der stelle der
mörder oder auch serienmörder der
natürlich in der umgebung des hauses von
bolli träsch sein unwesen treibt
ich war die tatsache dass halt diese
aufnahmen von draußen mit im video sind
bedeuten hat letzten endes dass diese
person die diese auch mal gerade gemacht
hat also der mörder dann die aufnahmen
an bord gegeben hat das war der matula
ich habe ich jetzt weiter verfolgt ich
würde ich auch gerne natürlich umlegen
ist ja klar also mein beruf trotzdem
jemand die aufnahmen für dein nächstes
youtube video macht sind
okay dann ist das scheint mir dann der
moment wo bonnie den mörder sieht also
ich meine sich heute direkt in die
kamera und dann kommt so ein schock
effekt und dann danach passiert aber
irgendwie nicht so viel auf jeden fall
[Musik]
wusste da sind mehr drin also versteht
was ich meine
also man kann natürlich jetzt zwei
sachen zu diesem videos aber keine wer
sagen das ist gefällt und so und mit
ihre zuschauer checken das nicht weil
die auch wahrscheinlich so jung sind die
von rebecca wing was wahrscheinlich auch
zum großen teil stimmt man könnte aber
auch sagen ja ok an halloween kann man
mal so ein video raushauen was nicht so
ganz wohl ist mir die sache es halt
selbst in diesem fall macht es einfach
keinen sinn
was war das jetzt gerade auffangen da
steht ein fenster alles klar also weiter
im text
meine wohnung wollte ich so zu
dekorieren und übrigens diesmal das ganz
große chaos draußen oder was ja das habe
ich auch mal gehört wie alle kennen den
radio funk an halloween wo genau durch
gegeben wird in welcher gegend welche
leute mit welchen masken rumlaufen man
hört davon ist ja klar
auch an der stelle wieder so ihr habt
nicht nur davon gehört so body selbst
hat doch gerade eben zu fenster geschaut
und die person da erblickt und hat sich
gehen es war wohl nur eine schwebende
kamera im moment aber der spaß beiseite
leute tut mir leid ich wie erkennt
falsches vorbild sein ich wäre ein gutes
vorbild für euch sein selbstverständlich
verändert sich die persönlichkeit von
leuten wenn sie eine 10 euro
karnevalsmaske aufgaben bisher ganz klar
die liebsten und nettesten menschen
werden plötzlich zu gewalttätern sobald
sie diese zehn euro kann weil
maske aufkommen insofern hat die gute
dame hier natürlich vollkommen richtig
drücken das denke ich kann das nicht
aber irgendwie macht ihm angst
wir müssen uns eigentlich aber explizit
dafür bedanken sehr geehrter mörder oder
rumtreiber oder wer auch immer diese
person ist ja draussen was dankeschön
noch mal dafür dass du so net fasst hier
filmaufnahmen die du gemacht hast hier
reden wir nicht darüber warum eine
kamera dabei das macht natürlich keinen
sinn für dich eigentlich aber vielen
dank an dich noch mal dass du die
filmaufnahmen die du gemacht hast dann
auch noch boni zugeschickt hat sonst
nächstes video der mich so nicht möglich
gewesen so langsam sehe ich wie so
halloween zur horror nacht wird also
übertragen wie kann man das denn
übersehen er steht litt wie eine person
mit dieser maske am fenster so das
fenster ist gut beleuchtet es gibt nicht
viel was wir sonst ablenken würde er
stehe sitzt draußen vorm fenster ist
mittlerweile so jetzt nämlich mal war
die wie soll das funktionieren
ich kann mich nicht schaden wenn ihr
mich nicht wahrnimmt so funktioniert die
ganze kaka nicht okay ich bin gruselig
und ihr müsst mir gefälligst zuschauer
die nicht mit englisch oder so aber dann
kann es mir gern
ok jetzt haben sie eigentlich mal
wahrgenommen danke warum das so lange
gedauert hat würde ich gern mal wissen
vielleicht schon um freund ist man
sollte gruseligen wesen doch bitte auch
die aufmerksamkeit geben ob beim
nächsten mal ein bisschen schneller
weiter gespielt heute und zwar haben die
mädels ich jetzt endlich meine
verteidigungsstrategie gegen diese
wirklich immense gefahr die davon
draußen auf sie einwirkt überlegt und
zwar sieht die folgendermaßen aus die
ihr gerät mit beiden hat sie eine gurke
geholt
ja wir wissen alle gurken sind sehr
effektive selbstverteidigung und die
beiden zusammen haben sich überlegt okay
was können wir machen
wir haben eine gurke wie können wir uns
jetzt über diese gurken aus maximal
schützen wie bestellte pizza
hier ist ein euro trinkgeld du ganz ganz
ganz kurz noch bevor du jetzt da wieder
zurück ist oder im auto ich wollte nur
sagen 1010 so ein mörder unterwegs da
hatte ich schon ein paar leute auf dem
gewissen hat er mir gemeint das ja heute
auch noch ein paar umlegen wollen würde
bisher wurde sogar noch halloween harald
man heute werden halt leute umgelegt
wird ob wir was soll das heißen wie
gurke hilfe nicht mehr überleben was ist
das denn das ist genau das konnten wir
die jugend in deutschland nicht erzählen
dürfen okay fair news gurken sind
essentiell wichtig zu überlegen
oh mein gott oh mein gott jetzt wird's
ernst jetzt was die beiden mädchen ist
schon jetzt nicht wissen ist dass
folgende leute und zwar diese personen
die diese maske da an hat man von
draußen klopft ist natürlich auf gar
keinen fall ein freund von ihnen auf
keinen fall
die person ist eigentlich nur so nicht
nicht schreibt das geld ist nicht teil
des videos ich wollte dich fragen ob du
noch hast du noch ein abo für die kamera
wenn mein akku ist gerade gegangen
die ganze geschichte verläuft dann so
weiter dass die beiden mädels ist dann
tatsächlich geschafft haben ich weiß
nicht wie sie diesem gefährlichen täter
entkommen konnten es ist mir wirklich
unerklärlich aber irgendwie und es
geschafft und es liegt wahrscheinlich an
der gurke haben sich mit der gurke im
schlafzimmer versteckt und dann kommt
eine nachricht vom freund der jüngeren
dieser braunhaarige und der freund
schreibt gruselt ihr euch lasst mal lief
und er fragt ok uns kurse ist ein ernst
es ist ein ernst woher hast du dein
kostüm
wieso ärgerst du uns ich habe denke ich
was in herzinfarkt bekommen alter ist es
dann ernst ach ja und wenn du dann die
frage beantwortet ob es dann ernst ist
das kostüm woher hast du das eigentlich
woher kauft man halloween kann man
halloween kostüme kaufen wo er soll so
hellwig außerdem haben wir sind
vielleicht sie tut so als wüsste sie
nicht wo mein halloween-kostüm mehr
bekommt
das war halt nicht
[Musik]
ach schade ja okay dann war es wohl doch
nicht der freund von der jungen damen
hier sondern tatsächlich dann neuer du
bonnie es stellt sich mir wirklich nach
wie vor die frage wie bist du an die
kamera aufnahmen von dem mörder gekommen
habt ihr mich so eine gemeinsame google
drive wo er sodann sagte ja ok ja ich
will dich zwar oben lägen aber solange
du noch lebst macht ein youtube kanal
ihre ich habe für videoaufnahmen fertig
so mach dein geld damit wunderbar also
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie diese
ganzen sachen zusammenpassen leute
vielleicht auch dazu eigentlich die dann
gerne unten damit ab in die kommentare
hier könnt ihr euch vorgeschlagen das
video oben könnt ihr mann haben das war
so weiter deutlich vor augen
macht's gut